so we're gonna watch today
from grace randolph beyond the trailers
talking with zack snyder she landed an
interview after that whole
birds of prey cathy anne fiasco she was
like
oh i'm going to show you i have sources
redemption i'm going to show you i have
connections
i'm going to get the man himself to be
sourced
i'm going to get zach snyder i mean this
is awesome for her and if you guys
actually watch her
i think some people clicked on the video
assuming it was one thing but really we
have a very non-biased point of view
uh when we did the whole breakdown of
that kathy and grace randolph going back
and forth on twitter
in terms of her landing an interview
with zack snyder at this time i gotta
give it to her out of anyone on youtube
right now that i could think of whose
videos i watch
she's the one who deserves it she's
written for dc she's a big dc supporter
she's an actual not just movie fan but
comic fan herself she's been an adamant
supporter for the dc eu
even like a defender when it was getting
a lot of hate
more than a lot of us grace randolph was
the one who
i'm like does this make sense that she
got this interview to me
it actually it makes a lot of sense it's
a 22 minute interview i'm excited to
check it out i imagine that we're gonna
have a lot to talk about
afterwards so we're gonna you know
switch to the good mike's these
after uh the reaction and then we'll
talk about you know whatever
i'm it's her so i'm assuming we're
probably gonna get some rich things out
of here
some awesome things to discuss so let's
get into it guys
look who we have here mr zach snyder
hello good morning damn look at the
quality on that how does it feel
look how handsome he is jesus christ
he looks so great right now so fresh
quarantine hair
100
[Music]
it's um well it's fun to be busy
i guess that's the uh that's the
important thing um
we have uh i'm working on fun
and now you know pretty much full time
on uh
justice league so uh yeah
you know the debt is for netflix right
yeah i made the dance for netflix
christilia um
now's the
i think yeah time think but damn look at
that look at the rest of the cast
jesus once i ripped my iceberg
i can't wait
full move zach you're breaking all the
rules including running time so there's
titanic
195 minutes gone with the wind
221 minutes but i hear your justice
league
is even longer yeah well um
you know i can't i can't be uh no one's
gonna accuse me of making short movies
that's uh
[Laughter]
like especially my with my director's
cuts is uh pretty
pretty uh that is you know because it
700
from commercials right so it was always
like hey
30 seconds maybe it's because of that i
was like yeah you were like i can't wait
to break free
in 30 seconds so um
yeah but uh yeah so you know and i have
sort of famously advertised the um
run time at two hours and 14 minutes i
don't know 214 minutes tomorrow
yeah two hours way shorter
pretty good
when it's now in its current state it's
gonna end up being
longer than that yet so exciting
217
material to uh the fans that get to see
all these crazy
and awesome new sequences and i think
that that's going to be really exciting
for everyone
so you can you tell can you reveal like
the ballpark of how long it's going to
be or is that stuff
mostly guarded secret it's a slightly uh
closing card
i just want you know the thing is like i
really want to um
what would i sort of uh talk about that
in the upcoming time because i'm still
working on it so i don't want to like
say because it's still if you want
people to be like where's the minutes
you promised me
and you're doing all of this from home
you know i had a wonderful time in 2017
i got to visit you and your team
on the warner brothers lot you had this
huge suite of offices a giant editing
bay
but now you got to do this movie from
home what's it like with
you and your team in quarantine it's
kind of like it's
it's challenging but you know i'll i'll
be um
you know honest about our working
situation and that it is
pretty efficient we've gotten to this
point where we can really sort of um
you know i have editorial upstairs and
then downstairs um
we have like a screening room so we can
watch the dailies and or
watch the visual effects as they come in
and then um
uh dodie and i have like this amazing um
sort of mirrored editing system so i can
see
your editor yeah so i can see exactly
what she's doing
and it's really it's a really an amazing
technological uh setup so it it's
it's allowed us the problem is you've
never uh
you can't leave it right you don't it's
oh yeah you'd be like two in the morning
you're like i have an idea
it's literally it's like it's
cracking on till like you know the wee
hours and we're just you know
you never i mean unless the kid's gonna
drag me out
uh yeah pretty much you know it's good
it's fun
i really like it we're in there 30 hours
a day
[Laughter]
so you know speaking of secretive you've
only shown your cut to a handful of
people
and it's already become legend that's a
lot of pressure
so what do you feel that the snyder cut
needs to deliver let me put on my
glasses
my graphic novel specs
[Music]
um you know
it's been a way to kind of allow
filmmakers and
and storytellers you know it's this kind
of affirmation of this concept that you
know storytellers matter
their stories matter and um i think
really the big pressure on me is just
for it to be exactly true to itself you
know
and i know that sounds like obvious but
you know we as storytellers and as
filmmakers
a lot of time you know there's a lot of
um
different powers that push and move and
change you know what you're doing as
you're doing it but
josh this process in this
project it really is an amazing
opportunity just to
and what i think the fans want is just a
very pure and
and and exact
uh version of the movie and that's what
i'm that's what i'm doing that's a great
answer
yeah that's a great question a great
answer damn it
i was like you handle that crazy
randolph
and some fans have been wondering how or
even if
your version of justice league relates
to the rest of the dceu
can yeah yeah it's a really it's a good
question and that
you know he's switching between producer
and writer
[Music]
five um old when it comes out
for me you know i've been living with it
for that long so
you know i think that like um
and and frankly the the dc you know
cinematic universe has
gone on it's branched like a tree and
blossomed and grown and
amazing in great ways like look i have a
i'm a producer on
um wonder woman yeah i'm super excited
about what patty's done with that movie
and like
it's gonna be it's amazing and i love
that you know how i love that character
i love doll it's like you know
very close to me and so you know
that that's a cool that's great that's
amazing i think
to me and um you look at like
what matt's doing with batman and um
you know you have this and by the way i
think
i'm super excited about that by the way
[Music]
robert snyder approved
you know for me in the like you know
where the movie falls
is it it it's sort of i i believe that
it really starts to represent its own
its own path you know it doesn't really
it's kind of separate now
from what i would say the dc universe
cinematic universe in continuity i think
it is kind of it's divergent
in that way and i think that that's a
good thing i think that you know the
power of people
for now yeah that's the cool strengths
is that sort of multiverse concept where
you know and also when they kind of put
filmmakers first and say you know what
guys
we want to hear your voice your
individual voices take these characters
and do a run and so show us what like
you know you would do um in sort of the
great tradition of
comic book writing and and runs that
have done and done with all these
amazing characters
so i think that that is a cool um and
amazing sort of canvas and so for me you
know i think justice league
you know i've heard someone say like oh
like so it's the
it's the you're entering the snyder
purse now
you know what i would and what you'll
see at justice league
and that member superman and man of
steel they are
there's continuity across
to continue that story that's so many
people
we were talking about this beforehand
you know in the run-up to this and i
loved your explanation that it is like
those great runs when you have these
really
amazing artists whose visions take over
a combo character
and just do like this really high art
version of what they would do with that
character if they were telling a story
yeah and that's and that's exactly how i
feel about it i just think that it's
like
these these characters will live long
long past
what we do and they'll they're going to
go on other adventures into like you
know
who knows where space and time and thank
god
so you're saying there could be a sequel
to the snyder cut
that's what i'm getting from it
[Laughter]
you know these these
actors sort of fill these shoes in this
way that i think people really care
about it is really
you picked them too you did a very nice
job we're gonna talk about that in a
minute but speaking of characters
i really like evil superman you like
evil superman
a lot of people just like batman don't
trust the guy
why do you think the darker side of the
man of steel is so appealing to people
and will we see more of that in the
snyder cup
well i thought
do i love the evil superman she's doing
good she's doing
[Laughter]
[Music]
this is a great interview it is a
journey with his character with his
with i love the idea of superman having
to like
reconcile his morality reconcile his
place
in on earth and reconcile like
his his chest hair i love
her i love
[Music]
you know the way he relates to humanity
and all those things as we all do with
our with our the normal relationships we
all have
in our daily lives so i think that when
you see
superman grappling with those things i
don't need these anymore relatable
you know um superman that's dark
what's up for superman that's dark well
yeah and i think
i think so like when i see superman like
having to figure out like what to do i
now can go like wow if i was superman
i could see you know because superman is
such an abstract character
in his powers and like what he's able to
do right anytime you can kind of bring
him
you know back down to earth he becomes a
lot more relatable and then
and i think and for that reason more
interesting but i do
have a huge respect for his like moral
code and he's
oh sure and his ultimate and i think his
ultimate
place as the sort of as as
uh as the top of the pyramid of the dc
superhero world oh totally
i think you have to you have to like
in the end he has to achieve that that
that so you feel you're taking ah with
your story
[Music]
sometimes he just has you know in some
of the confrontations in batman v
superman
uh and also you know the way he is just
so powerful
uh from what we see you know the
glimmers we've only just seen in justice
league
and i think also obviously the nightmare
stuff so i think that that stuff's
really compelling
yeah and and frankly really fun because
you know we kind of have these like
now now like with the resurrection sort
of
theme concept um easter
you know who is he now like what is he
when you touch the like
you know the eternal in the sense that
coming back from
the grave like how how are we changed by
that you know
charles sweden explored that perfectly
fine such a
deep rich character study
why did you decide to do so many scenes
with bruce
while a lot of other films focus largely
on batman
uh you know i don't think it was like i
don't think it's necessarily a conscious
like decision to say oh let's just do
let's study let's use bruce as the sort
of conduit but
i mean i think in these two movies in
bds and
in justice league because batman
is forced to do a lot of sort of um
he's doing a lot of bruce wayne
activities bruce wayne
yeah like being out in the world you
know what i mean bruce doesn't really
it's hard for batman to go to a party or
it's not you know anywhere
it's a costume party
i think that you know um bruce
in his um in his
humanity again i think is an amazing
thing to see him like you know because
we know everyone loves batman batman's a
badass and that's
just how it is but the why of that i
think is really is really cool
i think so dude everyone loves his
parents
[Laughter]
what what they did
well you know your casting decisions
have really helped shape the entire dc
eu it might have blossomed but you were
the seed
and i think you've done a fantastic job
and jason momoa
and gal gadot turned out especially well
and fans felt that aquaman and wonder
woman worked on justice
in the 2017 theatrical cut what can fans
look forward to seeing from those
characters
in your version well
you know i i'm not sure again
yeah you know i'm famously and it's 100
sure i haven't seen the theater
yeah and so i'm not 100 yeah [ __ ] that
one
can we get a quick [ __ ] josh wheaton
forget that thing you don't care about
that old version anymore but
i think they're saying yeah if you if
you make it as a
you know comparison yeah yeah i'm not
i'm not sure but
um i i felt like
and um we were excited about
just how those two kind of loaners
um would have to you know
um be incorporated into this team
setting and like
how they would react and what they would
do and meanwhile
you know wonder woman has other things
going on as she looks forward to the
future and like what is her
what is her where's what is her place um
and his time joshua didn't explore that
perfectly
yeah you know with all those those
light-hearted jokes he threw a lot of
balls in the air with them
but both of them so i think well there's
like full-on character development that
we're going to see in this this is crazy
i know aquaman
the movie managed to actually get me
access yes
but wonder woman 84 takes place before
this movie so
it's an interesting timeline if you will
but i do think that to um
again to try to to um
look at it as a really sharp continuity
i think would be a mistake
i think there is a like i say i think i
those movies now
you know in a lot of ways the theatrical
version probably of justice league
is a tiger is tighter in continuity
with the other but the ones that
followed yeah
because frankly that was a movie that
they
kind of they were in charge of the
elements
right they got him [ __ ] up you know
it ruined my baby um jack jordan
saying you know zach could just you know
go finish your vision
it hasn't you know it's going to be
divergent in some
way you know it's just it's just by its
nature but you know and i think that's
the thing you want because it just
allows more
more and more well dc is famous for
doing these great graphic
novels and you know these stories that
come out and are really
the signature of the people who are
making them so yeah
great comparison run your fingers throw
your hair one more time zach
just one more time and flip your glasses
especially today with black lives matter
uh
what do you think his expanded story and
you know you're gonna have a lot more of
his parents as well
what do you think they'll be what do you
hope they'll be adding to your film
you know i from the beginning when when
chris terry and i started talking about
this story we really
wanted to make um cyborg the heart of
the movie
and and ray from the beginning
um we loved ray and cassie moray and i
i get along with macy he's here he's a
close friend
and um we um
we talked to him a lot about like what
cyborg's time has come
i mean just as far as like where he is
when we meet him here he is at the end
of the movie
it's really he represents in a lot of
ways this is sort of
what it is to create community and what
it is to like
you know bring people together i think
that that you know
we made like i said we made the movie
you know in 2016
and i just think that you know those
themes are more important now than ever
so it's
really it's it's a really amazing and
fun
um to be able to work with ray and be
able to bring
you know that character to life because
it's so important
well finally your interaction with fans
is unparalleled
and you told me you have pharaoh
surprise coming up with justice con
later this week
all right all right right right that's
why i'm here to plug this
um
and by the way i'm super excited about
just gone because it's
you know it's a bi-fans for fans
con which i don't know if there's too
many of those going on at this scale
you know guys
um putting it on is just amazing and so
i was more than honored to like
do whatever i could but it's by the fans
they put it together that's crazy
yeah that's cool and um a lot of my
friends
like literal friends are a part of it so
that's fine uh
and so um yeah
i i i i'm gonna i i may show a clip
he's definitely doing
yeah check it out okay
i'm right i think i'm right after 5 30
p.m
so really eastern time we're all so
happy for you
screw comic
too kind it's too con i take the fans
because it's not about them
you know like i said this wouldn't
happen
without them i might have watched the
theatrical cut cheers okay you too
you know i i've really noticed and i
think grace's interview
here is a perfect example of it
[Music]
is that these zoom quarantine
interviews are just so much more natural
and feel so much more conversational
yeah let's get the mics on yeah i think
this is a wonderful interview and i
think a lot of people are going to be
covering
information from here good on you beyond
the trailer grace randolph
people are already covering this
interview and breaking it into multiple
parts
yeah if it's a really rich interview my
main takeaway that i had
listening to this was you hear so much
about missing plot points per se
you know dark side abundance of other
characters who were supposed to be
featured in here and what i really
got from this interview with what zach
was talking about
with the characters he really knows the
emotional character journey of these
individuals
that's what he wanted to capture here on
screen yeah him talking about superman's
resurrection
anytime i hear about that i'm always
associating like black suit superman i
can't wait to see that oh it's gonna be
cool
and he was talking about what does that
do to an individual
going into the afterlife or something
and then coming back to earth
who is that person oh like yeah that's a
great question the one that came out a
few years ago didn't do anything with
that really
it was just like ah pet cemetery jokes
you know i'm gonna clarify again because
i'm gonna keep saying this i had so much
fun
with uh joss whedon's justice league i
thought it was a fun saturday morning
cartoon monday now yeah that being said
i'm really under the impression that i'm
i'm probably gonna
love this significantly more especially
with that answer that he gave
about the purpose of doing this and with
the pressure because there's so many
jokes that go around about zack snyder's
justice league you know there's so much
hype for this
how can it possibly live up to the hype
so when she asked that question
i was really like paying attention to
what how is he gonna answer this
exactly and he actually gave the perfect
answer
this film is championed the
support to get this made the movement
is all based off of the people who
already love
his work with man of steel and batman v
superman well he says he just wants to
make the purest
film that he can make basically like
whatever his intent was
with this he's got to honor that 100 and
it sounds like he has even more free
reign than before
not really having to worry about length
at all with this addition unless the
hbo max has a specific idea of how they
want to divide up the episodes with a
certain runtime but
on streaming services especially they're
very lenient
with like this one be 40 minutes and
this one be an hour it doesn't really
matter
anything to get people to come onto our
platform seriously cut it up into 100
parts if you want we'll just mess them
out for 10 years whatever
i really think that this is going to be
something special regardless because
this sounds like a true artist vision
and what the way he talked about the
characters like even with aquaman and
wonder woman i didn't even
think about that perspective because
it's not it's kind of there
with aquaman ish loner but then he you
know he
joins the team you know that's mostly
just to get like a cool you know early
on bit of like oh we gotta do like a big
convincing badass moment with somebody
they hit the outline yeah yeah exactly
no it does
yeah and it you know serves its purpose
to the overall plot you can't do it with
everybody so we do with augments um but
with aquaman and wonder woman
whatever type of relationship or
exploration of these two loners who
really don't want to be
part of a team that even makes more
sense to have
batman be the lead of the justice league
in this version
of a guy who was especially a loner type
character in bvs
and is now learning to put that to the
side so he can unite people and then see
what that does with the characters of
aquaman
like that my main takeaway with this is
like oh i don't know why it hasn't
really been the main discussion is the
character exploration
well the whole idea that cyborg being
you know the the newest
and and is he maybe not the youngest
among them but one of the younger among
them and least experienced among them is
the one who brings them all together
into that sense of community
and the importance of that and i did
also appreciate going off you know
uh what you said about you know him
wanting to make the best film possible
and the most
honest to his trilogy and completing
this trilogy of films because you know
say what you will
and we've certainly said a lot about man
of steel bvs and then
whedon's justice league it certainly
doesn't feel like a completed trilogy
he's also just really great
at selling you his vision and and the
passion that drives it and i think one
thing that's really cool
here and cool for him and just cool to
see is the amount of yeah
fan appreciation because it's clear that
this guy's doing his
thing like this is his vision but he's
also uh
seemed like he's really demonstrating
like to even premiere clip at a fan
generated event when comic con is going
on you know and i don't know if there's
any kind of correlation between the two
but
it seems like a very passion driven
project that does
make me really curious to see the
completed version and it makes me wonder
if i
might you know further appreciate you
know in in backwards fashion that the
previous two films or something like
that i haven't seen his director's kind
of bvs
and any uh further cut of man of steel
but i like demanded steal decently
enough
yeah i think that this could be a really
nice completion especially with his
superman because i feel like superman is
one that people were a little bit iffy
on when man of steel happened because
you had your purists who were like this
isn't my superman but i feel like what
he's talking about about him being
just delving further into that alien how
do i relate to everybody what is my
place in this world how do i use my
power for these people and who am i now
that i've been resurrected like to see
all those things maybe actually be
realized by a movie that sounds like it
will be a pretty hefty like that does
sound
exciting and substantial in a way that
that does make me happy like i
remember when they chose him i was
initially like yeah go zack snyder and
this is kind of like coming back to what
i appreciate about him
and so like this was really cool to see
in this interview well he talks about
superman being this pinnacle and he was
pretty much hinting at he's supposed to
arc into the superman
yeah we know and love yeah and this is
the exploration of
the journey to him getting there yeah
and so i do
think that this would ultimately make
the other two
feel even better because you'll get a
completed
tail here which makes championing for
this
that much more important in a certain
extent
yeah because like you didn't really get
the completion of that and then you got
something else
he establishes other things i'm sure a
lot of people are really harping on you
know like with the
dcu continuity he's excited for batman
he's excited for batman he's gay i mean
that actually can go a long way in the
fact that he decided okay all right ben
affleck's island we're gonna do a
completely different batman right now
him showing his support what sounded
like a very
genuine moment of like yeah i'm really
excited to see what he does with it
doesn't just sound like a pr thing that
you're required to say
registers is genuine here to say the
least it does which is cool to have his
backing on it
but also you know this the thing with
the dc
eu especially what they did with crisis
on infinite earths
really established a hardcore multiverse
so
to say like yeah this is just you know
like with what dc does their
multi-verses or their one-offs or
they're
you know specific types of adaptations i
think there's a lot of weight
for that especially in this scenario
because
you could essentially depending on how
big of a hit this
is and how well loved it is he could
continue
with one of these characters or make
another justice league and again
that speaks to the prowess of the
producer that zack snyder is because he
actually did what i thought was the
unthinkable for my own personal taste
which was yeah
and especially i think the multiverse
does help a lot because people get
really charged up when it looks like
this is our only superman for the
foreseeable future or batman or whoever
but this actually got me excited to go
man think he could finish justice league
and just go off into his own snyder
verse while other things happen in the
dc universe and then we can have a more
dark
a little bit more harsh version of the
world and it would be perfectly fine
and it could breathe on its own instead
of having to fulfill all these other
marvel-sized expectations
you know you can correct me on the words
here but i imagine there's like a dc
galaxy and then within there are the
multiple
universes right automatically if you
look at it as like the dc
galaxy yeah i think i'm using the
science terminology proper here
that would mean that even within the
multiverse all these properties are
still connected these universes have
something where you know
flash or someone could travel to that
other universe or whatever
this universe is linked by the fact that
every molecule has a little dc
logo on it well you know i'm just saying
that like you could have
a universe hopping if you want to down
the road
which is what crisis on infinite earth
was really doing to establish that no we
can cross over these other universes are
separate but we can cross over so
depending on this i mean they
they they're they have free reign to
play around with
continuity they do you know yeah i hope
this pans out well
and for cyborg yeah i've been hearing
the whole thing about cyborg being the
heart of it uh for the longest time
yeah i'm actually watching doom patrol
there's a cyborg character on there who
is great really real three-dimensional
character
it's so much easier it's weird i imagine
it's a very different type of
interpretation for what ray fisher would
be doing in justice league but after
getting a lot more familiar with a very
human take on
cyborg in doom patrol it's a lot easier
for me
to imagine how he could be the heart and
soul of this film just getting you know
that much more acquainted with the
character
overall i did think this was a a
wonderful interview
i mean i make it as long as you want
zach like
more episodes the merrier yeah well and
it's done something really funny to me
which is it's brought so much
love like every time i hear about this
project now it's just attached with this
like avalanche of love and so that
really gets me more excited than
anything like i'm actually feeling like
bright and excited to see what they come
out with you know
it's because we didn't think this would
ever happen yeah it's like we were never
sure we always wanted a man he's been
resurrected
we always he's going to arc into the dc
filmmaker we've always wanted him to be
we we had hoped for it i signed the
petition years ago how many petitions
are signed
that don't actually pan out so the fact
that this is actually happening is it is
a big deal it's still got its haters and
whatever
but screw them let's just let's get on
let's just get let's use that footage
yeah yeah great job upgrades right now
there's a wonderful interview and
these one people will be talking about
and thanks for watching our breakdown
grace
yeah all right guys well you can go
click on uh the original video link in
the description box check out grace's
channel if you haven't done so already
subscribe to the real rejects
click that notification bell get
notified whenever we got a youtube video
up what did you think of this video last
but not least
bradley bledsoe bradley is a handsome
handsome gentleman all the way from the
state of fried chicken kentucky oh boy
man is happily married works on video
essays does covers of songs
write scripts multi-talented gentlemen
over here sexy he goes down on his wife
three times a week at least oh man
minimum
minimum it's a beautiful thing what he's
doing because
because a lot of guys aren't willing to
even in this day and age and you just
should be able to now
weirdly like talk down on yeah and
bradley goes against the grain
and he goes hey i love you and then she
offers to go down
on him and he goes no no no no no
it still doesn't work only on my
birthday
once on the mountain
we take our pilgrimage every year up the
mountain then
and only man but not today sorry bradley
we gave you a funnier shout out on your
on the live stream but thanks for being
here bradley this is the run off of
that sorry i'm sorry